what's going on y'all it's Miles Turner
here
I got my Boy Slim coming in and I'm
going to be surprising him with the t-so
watch himself big slim what's good man
appreciate you making the journey
slim is someone that is very near and
dear to my heart I started working with
him when I was about sixth grade you
know he's more than just a strength
coach Mentor he's a life coach for me
can't help but smile when he's talking
to him what you got on your wrist right
there this is the same watch yeah I'm
always everything's on time this is one
of the things that you know you can
always look down and still just remember
our journey together remember where
we're going and all them times you're
gonna spend a track together I want to
make sure I hooked you up today with the
tiso Super Sport which that love
it I'm gonna upgrade a little bit
wow she still got the stopwatch on into
what not training folks back home we
still do your thing so we do what you
got to do with it my man it's my man
only the beginning we just scratched the
surface
[Music]